hello everyone uh welcome back from this
short break uh it was my great pleasure
to introduce sushant we'll be giving you
our first tutorial Talk of the boot camp
um sushant is a professor at the
University of Toronto uh where he's been
doing a number of fantastic uh work on
uh broadly on algorithm design with a
real emphasis on graph optimization and
solving graph optimization problems
um he's received a number of awards from
his uh for for his work best paper
Awards so research fellowship and I
think his research very well fits into
all the themes and the works of the
program in terms of the broad themes of
the programs had a number of results I
think have been really influential in
pushing the field forward on laplacian
system solving on sparsification very
recently on solving Max flow in almost
linear time and a broader set of
problems everything is in a great
position to give this uh first tutorial
talk on graph linear algebra so thank
you very much
thank you Aaron that was a very generous
introduction and thank you all for being
here it's uh it's a pleasure to uh to be
at Simon's again in fact I was here as a
fellow exactly 10 years ago at their
first program and it's it's an honor to
give give the first talk and somewhat
nerve-wracking at the first boot camp
not because this will be a difficult for
any of you but I think uh the tricky
thing is pitching it right without
boring you uh in the first talk in the
morning so so let me ask a couple of
quick questions to sort of set the pace
for this
how many of you feel comfortable
defining a graph laplacian
okay that's a good chunk of the audience
I mean if you feel comfortable defining
a normalized graphical
right I might have to re-speed my talks
but this um so what's the goal what's
the goal of my talk right like I'm going
to give you prison three lectures
said my goal is to first set the a
common grounding for all of us right to
define the language we commonly use in
this subfield this describe how graphs
can be treated as continuous objects how
do you study them using a linear
algebraic perspective
and then we'll build on these techniques
in the next two lectures but the very
first one today is going to be really
basic uh my goal is that all of us every
single one of us is familiar and
understands the basic basic notation in
the space basic language and if you have
any question any doubt anything you
think on the slides is wrong please feel
free to stop me
and another caveat I am trying out a
slightly new presentation format uh I
hope this will go smoothly but the small
hiccups please forgive me
super so
what how do graphs and linear algebra
interact right so let me quickly start
by actually showing you three common
processes that can be defined on graphs
that are fundamentally linear algebraic
processes here's one that you all know
of
or it's a random walk on the graph right
I start with a single vertex and then at
every step this vertex hops over to a
random neighbor
nice and you can ask the question what
is my probability distribution at after
T steps of a random block
foreign
ly unrelated to graphs
I set up an electrical Network a
resistive electrical Network so every
Edge is a resistor
and I want to send in current at a
Vertex called The Source at the second
vertex called the sink
how does the current distribute itself
throughout the network
right
here's a third process some of you might
be less familiar with
but it's a process arising from physics
you take a continuous uh let's say let's
take a continuous Taurus and we'll
discretize it to sort of simulate it
computationally and I give you an
initial heat distribution where your two
vertices here the ones in white when the
animation begins are really hot and
everything else is cold how does this
heat distribute itself throughout the
medium
right it turns out once you discretize
the space this is again exactly a linear
algebraic process on this discretized
graph
all right and I'll come back to these
processes once we've given our basic
definitions to see how do these relate
to the basic algebraic parameters
okay super so let me bore you for the
next five minutes at least most of you
who know these definitions but I want to
make sure all of us agree on the same
definitions of these objects so you
assume that the graphs are undirected
excellent thank you so the first thing
for this talk uh so let me repeat the
question the question was
um whether I'm going to assume that the
graphs are undirected
throughout my talks I'm going to assume
that these graphs are undirected but
they have non-negative weights on the
edges
right so so our notation is going to be
I have a set of n vertices
and there are M edges on this graph
undirected edges and each Edge has a
non-negative weight w of e associated
right so through I mean through the
through the semester you will see the
applications to directive graphs but but
the basic notation and all of these
properties are way easier to Define for
undirected graphs
all right here's one that all of us have
seen in undergrad how do you write a
matrix that describes the graph right
and the most simplest one is the
adjacency Matrix
it's a Vertex by vertex Matrix where the
i j entry is the weight of your Edge
connecting vertex I and vertex J
let's see a few simple examples well
this is why I chose a different format
so that I could easily show you uh
graphs and drawings these are all based
on code that is executed in Julia with a
package written by Dan Spielman so so
here here's the code you can write that
I want to construct a path graph of
length 10. and here and it gives me the
adjacency matrix it's a 10 by 10 matrix
where say the 1 2 the 2 3 and all the
way I I plus one entry is one indicating
the I to I plus one edge here
right all of us find that this is the
symmetric adjacency Matrix for our for
our path graph
if I instead had a cycle now you also
get the 10 to 1 Edge so I get an entry
in the ten one
ten one uh and 110 positions in the ages
all of these dots are zeros right so
it's a sparse Matrix
uh
it runs for edges
if I instead add weights on these edges
as we said that we want to indicate the
width
on on the locations so I I waited the
cycle one two three four five six seven
and they show up
they show up in the corresponding
locations in the matrices
so in the previous size laplacians.ring
graph outputs and adjacency Matrix
that's right and then I can con so the
laplacence is the name of the package
it's the name of the package
and then you can convert it to laplaces
no that's okay
all right here is a slightly more
interesting example a complete graph
right so we will treat the complete
graph so I have 10 vertices
every eye is connected to every other
vertex
without a self Loop so you get the all
ones Matrix without the diagonal
super easy so far
excellent
here's another very simple
definition associated with graphs
I'm going to mostly use weighted degrees
right combinatorial degree will for most
reasons be relevant for studying
properties linear algebraic properties
of graphs they'll be interesting for
time complexities but but I will
distinguish them if we use them so for
now think of just weighted degrees which
is the sum of
all the weights of the edges incident on
your vertex
right and I can stack them into a
diagonal matrix which we will call the
degree Matrix
so it's a v by V diagonal matrix where
the ith diagonal entry is the weighted
degree of the vertex I
super good so so two matrices adjacency
and degree so far it turns out these are
while simple and natural
they are not the most interesting to
study with respect to linear algebraic
Properties or graph
the first one we will study will be the
next one uh I have a couple of examples
here very easy so here's degrees for the
for the ring graph
uh there are two constant on the
diagonal for the weighted one again you
sum up the weights so for this vertex I
have 1 plus 2 is 3 that shows up on
vertex 2 here
foreign
so good so let's get to our first
interesting Matrix that's called The
laplacian Matrix
I will Define it differently rather than
telling you what are the entries of a
matrix I'm going to define it by its
quadratic form okay what is the quotient
form so give me a vector X that assigns
values to your real real values to your
vertices right so it's a vector in R to
the V
the quadratic form of this Vector with
the Matrix L is X transposal x
that's called the quadratic
so my laplacian is going to be the
unique symmetric
real Matrix
that achieves the following quadratic
form right let's take our time to parse
this so sum over your edges in the graph
weight of your Edge
multiplied by the difference in the
values in X across your range X U minus
x v squared
sum over your edges weight of the edge
difference across the edge squared
and my laplacian will be defined as the
unique symmetric Matrix that achieves
this quadratic form
okay this one let's let's see some
examples so let's maybe first infer the
entries
from this definition let's take a very
simple example I give you an edge an
unweighted edge UV
what do I want it's quadratic form to be
just simply X U minus x v squared
but I can write this quadratic form as
an inner product squared
the inner product of x
with the vector 1u minus 1B what are
these vectors one U is a vector that's 0
everywhere except with a one at U so
it's an indicator Vector of U
and one V is an indicator Vector of V
so 1 U minus 1B gives you a vector
that's 1 on U minus 1 on V and 0
everywhere else
right and this inner product square is
my quadratic form for a single h
right everyone with me
so now I can write this I can open it up
to see what is my explicit Matrix my
explicit Matrix is now the outer product
of this Vector one U minus 1. 1 U minus
1B times one U minus 1 V transpose and
that gives you a rank one V by V Matrix
and this rank one V by V Matrix has one
on the U diagonal one on the V diagonal
minus 1 on the UV of diagonals 0
everywhere else
right that's the opacity of a single
edge
and we can easily now generalize this to
a laplacian of a general graph so a
laplacian remember was the quadratic
form with the sum of weights of the edge
times difference of the edges squared I
know how to write the difference of the
H squared using an H laplacian so now I
can just plug that in to say that my
laplacian should be
some overages weight of the edge times
the LaPlace n of the h
right and this gives me a very
like what you might have seen as the
initial definition of a laplacian is
that on the diagonals you end up getting
the weighted degree
and on the off diagonals you get the
negative of the weight of the edge
so I can write that as the degree Matrix
the weighted degree Matrix that we
defined previously minus the weighted
adjacency Matrix that we Define
let me pause here
see if there are questions
nothing
because
oh all right so so when I said quadratic
form I meant it's symbolically so for
all X it should be equal so you should
think of it as X's are really variables
right so so the x i x i j term on the
left should be the same as the x i j
terminal right so I am entered
symbolically and all X thank you
another question
okay excellent thank you so let's
let's just see a few examples before
we'll come back to our motivating
processes on graphs so here is the
laplacian of a cycle the laplacian of a
cycle gets two on the diagonals because
every vertex has 80 degree 2 and you get
minus ones on the two edges and entries
because it has two two edges to your
adjacent vertices with which one
here's the laplacian of the weighted
cycle so for this vertex 2 my degree was
3 so I got 3 on the diagonal
and minus 1 and minus 2 corresponding to
your two edges
right right and it's symmetric right so
you have minus 1 minus 1 minus 2 minus
two
good
most of your bored and probably uh this
is slow I understand uh bear with me for
five more minutes and then we will
uh things will get more interesting
all right what about the complete graph
this one I'm going to also write
algebraically this will be interesting
for us so the complete graph on 10
vertices gives me 9 on the diagonal
right because there's no self Loop so
you're connected to nine as the vertices
and every other entry is -1
so this can be written as
n n on the diagonal minus the all ones
over Matrix right so it's n times your
identity Matrix
minus the outer product of the all ones
Vector so this is my notation for the
all ones Vector just a big bold one will
be all ones rank like it's a column
Vector of all one so one one transpose
gives you a matrix with all ones
excellent good here is the second
Matrix that can be tricky to Define and
and in fact even within the community
you will see you will see confusion in
the way it's defined between the Matrix
and its transpose so I will try to stick
to one notation so this is a matrix
called The Edge vertex incidence Matrix
Edge vertex is going to be M by n
right so it's an e by V
Matrix usually denoted as B
so it's if I index into the rows every
row is indexed by an edge
right so the if the edge is UV
that rho is going to get
so it has to be a v v dimensional Vector
right my my V dimensional Vector is now
going to be 1 U minus 1 V if the edges
from U to B
I should have expected a question here
good thank you Bob
so the graph is undirected but I'm going
to pick an arbitrary orientation
right so pick you can you can pick any
one direction U before V one of them as
the head the other is the 10th
in the so here it does make a difference
like you will get you'll get either the
row or it's negative but in the rest of
the definitions it will not matter but
you have to pick one consistent signing
arbitrary
of every edge of every Edge
right so for every Edge pick one sign
right between the two end points pick
one of them as the head the other one is
the tail
and put a one on the head and minus one
on the tail and that will give you your
B Matrix so it's so so B is unique only
after you specify the sign
right but for more for all the
properties we'll talk of the signing
will not matter right so pick any one
consistent side there's another question
good no you do thank you so so this is a
this is a it's an it's a very good
question of how do you how do you
actually think of these matrices so when
I drew these matrices for example here
right uh the natural way to read a
matrix is oh this is entry one one uh
you know one one one two and so on so
that means I need to number the vertices
in order to sort of get rid of uh this
another mapping from vertices to number
it's useful to think of these matrices
actually being indexed by vertices right
I give you this vertex and this vertex
and that will index into an entry here
right so think of the rows and the
columns being indexed by vertices rather
than big numbers it's it is the same
thing but it's sort of implicitly
assumes this mapping you don't have to
make explicit about what the
what is the numbering of the vertices
good and
is ordering all the vertices to Define
consistent signs or I'm good thank you
so the question was do I need to
do these signs need to be consistent
with the total ordering on the vertices
not at all in fact it's impossible to be
consistent right if I just have a
triangle then they cannot or like oh
okay sorry so you like you can pick an
order and order them left to right
and get a signing was not necessary
another question
let me show you an example of B and then
we can come back to this so so here's
I've taken a simpler graph because this
one's trickier so
it's a four it's a click on four
vertices right so how many edges do I
have I have six edges I'm going to get
six rows one two three four five six
each row corresponds to one edge with a
single one and minus one indicating the
two endpoints
right so it's a six by four Matrix in
the case of
the four geek
right everybody with me now
excellent
so what is the relation of the V Matrix
to the laplacian
here's a simple observation so remember
the laplacian was some over here edges
weight of the edge times the laplacian
of the edge
which was a rank 1 Matrix with the same
Vector one U minus one B one U minus 1B
transposed this is exactly
B transpose w b
so where B transpose is your M by n ah
this should read
uh yeah so I'm not defined W but W is
just a diagonal matrix
containing the weights of the edges
so it's n once I take the transpose on B
I get n by m
by m m by n so it's an N by n Matrix so
the dimensions check out
but this is exactly the laplacian it's a
sum of these rank one entries scaled by
your weights
question
can I is this is this is this proof
immediate to all of us or shall we spend
a few more minutes on shall I explain
this proof
right this way is like it's really
looking at The Columns of B and just
rewriting it sorry the rows of B and
rewriting that b transpose B can be
written as these outer products
it's uh like if I were to write a proof
I would not do anything more than
bookkeeping just bookkeeping the entries
but it's exactly an expression
the product of a matrix with its
transpose
okay thank you so good so let's go
motivating examples that we started with
how are these processes connected to the
matrices we just defined
so the random work can in fact uh be
connected really easily uh as the
following so as as you take steps of the
random work the probability evolves
right and if I denote p as superscript t
to be the probability at time
probability of the vertex so it's a
probability distribution over the
vertices at time t
then after one more step of random walk
the probability evolves exactly as the
following it's a times D inverse times
the probability at step t
right and here's how I like to think of
this and like you know if
so what was A and B always forget good
sorry so a is your weighted adjacency
Matrix
right d is the diagonal weighted degree
right and how do I remember this like
when when I started out like I would
always be confused where should the D go
but here's how we should think of it
think of the input output process that
this sequence of matrices works with
okay so I index into a Vertex here that
gives me the probability at vertex V
I divide it by the degree of the vertex
V right by the some weighted degree and
then that gets distributed by your edges
onto your neighboring vertices
and that's collected to get to give you
the next probability distribution
right so this is a this is a useful way
to sort of always think of products or
matrices right you think of it as an
input output process
and it will all it will help you get
uh get the orders right if if it's
confusing
right
super what about heat diffusion this is
another example we saw it turns out heat
diffusion can be explicitly
characterized by What's called the Heat
the heat diffusion equation which on a
discretized graph looks like this the
rate of change of your temperature
Vector with respect to the time
is given with the negative of the
laplacian of the graph multiplied by the
temperature at time t
simple equation that can actually
explicitly be solved
to give
exponential of The Matrix laplacian
minus t
so this gives you so this is the Matrix
exponential I won't need it often if
you've never seen it with the easiest
way to define Matrix functions is to
think of the power series
so I write down the power series for the
Matrix TL
right take the same power series for e
to the minus X plug in t times The
Matrix
that infinite Matrix It converges it's
easy to prove that infinite like
summation viewed as a matrix gives you
the Matrix exponential
multiply that Matrix exponential with
your initial distribution that gives you
the distribution at time t
there's another interesting view of this
that I will
uh that I will not be able to prove but
it's actually a very nice exercise to
see if you are comfortable with it it
turns out this process
is exactly an infinite decimal random
walk
right at every time step t
you'd look at the current distribution
you look at the distribution after one
step of random work but
take a convex combination with an E
infinitesimal amount of the of the Step
Up of after one step right that's at t
plus DT
and you write that out that it gives you
exactly this equation
so this is this Matrix exponential in
some sense captures a continuous time
random walk over the graph
questions
is that is that consistent with the
physics too it seems like that there's
sort of
think of that random Hawk as being the
distribution of of uh kinetic energy
so right so good so I don't know if they
are able to derive it from this like a
statmic perspective and then uh and then
say that this is how to connect like
often you would see the either the heat
equation is wrong here's how he evolves
yes right but I but I like to interpret
it exactly this way yeah uh but but it's
hard to be formal about it because
you're actually working with sort of a
Continuum of particles it's not obvious
than that the energy should move like a
random work
right so so I don't know how to convert
that intuition into a formulas
um I think this if you look at like
[Music]
okay
this is basically just like how like
Fourier improve the heat equation gives
you heat flow only space thank you so
more or lessons
let me repeat for the folks uh listening
on on live stream so so iron I am here
just kind of commented that if you did
the same process on an infinite 2D grid
on an infinite 2D grid the the
eigenvectors are basically your signs
and cosines right in both in both
directions and this is exactly how the
heated question was first proved by
poisson
right but this one this is a process
that's more General you can Define it on
in on any graph on any weighted
undirected
right let me take a third example uh
which uh which is also very interesting
physics motivated again uh this was the
example for the currents right so I want
to send one unit of current in through
this Source vertex out through the sync
vertex how does the current distribute
itself I will let me derive
these expressions
with you in rather than give them to you
I fear so here's here's how it works so
so let me Define a vector of Demands on
the vertices the demand is the net
flow on that vertex so here the demand
Vector is plus one
because one current flows in minus 1
here because my one current flows out
zero everywhere else because everywhere
else I want the net current to be
conserved
right so that's my demand Vector I want
to find out what is the corresponding
current vector
so we will derive this from the minimum
energy principle in physics so the
minimum energy principle says that the
current will distribute itself
so that
subject to the constraints the total
energy of the current is the minimum
possible
and what is the energy of my current
on edge I or rather Edge e the current
is the current uh sorry the energy of
the current is the current Square
divided by the resistance
sorry the current Square multiplied by
levels I squared r right that's that's
from high school physics
okay so I'm going to write that in terms
of as a formula so it's minimum I want
to find a current that minimizes my
energy which is half
I transpose RI this is sum over edges
resistance of the edge current squared
right R is just a diagonal matrix with
the resistance of the h e on the eth
diagonal
so it's I mean it's a simple quadratic
form but I'm writing it in terms of
matrices because it will be easy for us
to reason so minimize this quadratic
form subject or constraint that the net
current on each vertex is given by the
demands
that's easy to actually capture using
our B Matrix
okay I I should have included a proof of
this but maybe maybe we can quickly see
this on the board
sorry
so I claim that if I have so at a Vertex
at a Vertex V
what is the net current
the net current
is going to be the sum
over
of the current over the edges that are
edges that come in that are directed
into
V
so okay let me
let me explain what do I mean by these
directions so remember for the edges
even though the graph is undirected we
chose an arbitrary consistent
orientation
we use the same orientation
to orient our currents right physically
a current has a Direction
so if if I had chosen to orient my Edge
this Edge from from vertex 1 to vertex 2
then a positive entry in the current
Vector will be interpreted as current
flowing from vertex 1 to vertex 2 and
the negative entry will be interpreted
as current flowing in the reverse
Direction
right so with that
what is my net current into this vertex
it's let's say this word Edge was
oriented outwards this size was oriented
inwards my net current is current coming
in
minus current going out
right
so current coming in is Edges directed U
to V
i e minus
sum over currents of currents going out
this is my net current on the vertex V
question
yes
are you still arbitrarily or ordering
directing the edges That's Right
cleaning the way you direct the edges
doesn't affect the energy that's right
because there's a square
right right so the way I direct the
energy the edges will not affect
the energy here because it is involved
in a square however it it affects your
interpretation of a positive entry in
this vector and interpretation of a
negative
but if I flip my interpretation I also
flip the entry in this
vertex
everything else
[Music]
particularly that's true like in a
physical system in a physical system yes
the energy is independent of which
direction the current is flowing in
that okay right yeah I mean these are
these are resistive networks right so
very simple elements current can flow in
either direction and the energy is
proportional to the square of the
current
right okay right so it's independent of
which direction it's flowing
another question
good
all right so so let's parse this a
little more so here's the net current
I want this to be equal to the demand on
vertex V so the width entry
in the vertex Infinity
this expression looks tricky first when
you look at it but I claim
that these set of equations remember
this is one equation for every vertex
is exactly equal to the following
equation D equals P transpose V
okay how let's let's just process this
again
think of the input
ah thank you
thanks
we transpose I so you can again think of
this as an input output connection right
so
in this time I will look at it this way
what's the output in the width
entry of DV
it comes from the product of width row
here
with your I Vector the inner product of
V throw with the ith Vector the V throw
it gets it gets an entry for every Edge
incident on V with a plus one on edges
that are coming in and a minus one non
edges that are going on
right so you get some plus one some
minus one for the edges that are going
out and the rest of them are all zeros
and this inner product with
I gives you exactly the net current
equation
right so I can capture the net current
constraints very naturally using the B
Matrix it says b transpose times the
current is exactly the demand vector
everyone with me more questions
super so this we can solve using if you
if you remember multivariable calculus
LaGrange LaGrange multipliers if not you
can also still do like a somewhat easy
proof because it's just a it's a very
easily differentiable quadratic function
to to write a minimizer using LaGrange
multiplies you you say that the gradient
of this function must be in line with
the transpose of B
right so differentiating this quadratic
form gives me
like the half goes away I just get Ri
the gradient of this function must be
the transpose
of your Subspace constraint multiplied
by some LaGrange variables unknown
LaGrange variables but these will turn
out to be exactly your voltages
right our initial problem did not have
voltages it just had currents
right and voltages pop out of the
LaGrange multipliers for solving this
constraint problem
so it says that my optimal solution must
be given by the resistance times the
current
is equal to is given exactly by B times
V so V is your voltages and BV gives you
v u v x minus v y
for an edge x y
questions
with me
yeah I now remember what D and R is okay
good right so so B is your e by B Matrix
I is our currents right so
so the resistance times the current is
given by BB PV gives you a vector with
difference of voltages across
it's a vector with Dimension M the
number of edges
the nth and the E entry for the edge X Y
is v x minus v y
yeah the r is
it's a diagonal matrix with resistances
for the end I mean they are the top
thank you that's one of those this is
just that's the second numbers and I
think that causes some of the confusion
uh thank you
okay I am really sorry
sorry thank you all right so these are
these are real vectors in the v space in
the e space this is a diagonal I'm sorry
I will fix that notice
okay but this is not a complete solution
yet right because I've introduced
unknown voltages
to solve it completely I'm going to use
the constraint right so multiply by R
inverse on both sides
and then multiply by B transpose what do
I get
I get B transpose I
which I know should be equal to the
demand
is equal to B transpose R inverse BB
right
this is my laplacian
right we already observed this before
that V transpose uh v b transpose w b is
the laplacian so if I Define a graph
where my weights are inverses of
resistances
then I will get
a graph LaPlace why the inverses so
think of always the case where an edge
is absent
if an edge is absent we said the wave
corresponds to away 0 but in an
electrical circuit an edge being absent
is infinite resistance
right zero current is Flowing there so
so so R inverse is very natural here
right so we Define a graph with the
weights of the edges being one over the
resistances and you get your graph of
passing
right but then I can explicitly solve my
voltages as the laplacian emerged times
the D vector
and the current as R inverse b l inverse
t
right so that determines all our
everything in our system the voltage is
the currents and the energy
right so I've cheated a little here
yes just
very very basic question so when you
write a matrix to minus one you never
mean Matrix inverse you just mean you
take each thing no thank you so always
because diagonal okay yeah okay
R inverse is so I will always use the
power minus 1 notation to mean the
Matrix inverse so
yeah for the resistance is because it's
a diagonal matrix powering R to like
looking at the Matrix inwards is just a
diagonal matrix with 1 over RI
on the diagonals
right but there's a related point that I
am cheating here turns out L is not
invertible uh I will
I will come to that in a second but but
the same expression you can Define it
very well right like it's this zero
inverse okay if you know the pseudo
inverse this is exactly the pseudo
inverse right for those who are not sure
you can think of pseudo inverses
thinking on the Kernel I will I I will
add something to make it uh make it a
complete make it a
an invertible Matrix I will invert that
Matrix and I will remove remove the
component in the kernel again right but
but you can ignore this if you're not
comfortable with this you can you can
interpret this expression
in a unique Way by plugging in the
pseudo inverse right so so allow me uh
allow me this little cheating and I will
use the inverse for now
all right so all of these processes are
now connected to
on basic graph matrices
excellent so
with that let me so we have 15 more
minutes I will use there is this time to
show you that some very basic spectral
properties of these matrices and how
they relate to the structure of the
graph this should be very simple and I
hope I can convey the proofs to you uh
so feel free to stop me if some
is not immediate
okay so before we dive in let me just
recall something from linear algebra
it's called the spectral theorem we'll
take the easy case our matrices are
symmetric right the ones that we're
dealing with other than B all our
matrices are symmetric so the spectral
theorem says every symmetric Matrix has
an orthonormal eigen decomposition
what does that mean let's interpret it
so that means that for a matrix M that
is symmetric I have n vectors
PSI 1 to cyan
that are in in Dimensions n vectors in N
dimensions
such that one each of these are
eigenvectors so
M times I I gives you Lambda at times I
well Lambda I is a scalar real variable
which is your eigenvalue I at eigenvalue
for The Matrix
and two these matrices are orthonormal
so if I take the dot product of the ith
vector and the jth vector
if I and J are the same I get 1 if
they're not the same I get 0.
right so n orthonormal vectors Each of
which are eigenvectors of The Matrix
and in fact the spectral theorem gives
us more it says that the Matrix itself
can actually be written
as a sum of these rank quantums where
the i x term is the eigen ith eigenvalue
Lambda I scaling the rank 1 Matrix PSI
isi transpose
so ith eigenvector times its iath
eigenvector transpose that gives you the
outer product so it's a rank one term
you scale that rank one term by the
eigenvalue and you sum it up you get
exactly the operator m
foreign
this actually a little more compactly if
I stack my eigenvectors as UI Columns of
this Matrix U
and I stack my eigenvalues in a diagonal
Matrix Lambda so the ith
ith entry or Lambda is Lambda I the is
diagonal entry of Lambda is Lambda I
then I can write M as U transpose U
Lambda U transpose
where U is actually a full or
orthonormal Matrix that means
U transpose U is the same as u u
transpose is and is the identity Matrix
in N dimensions
right
this is one theorem that's that's
actually tricky to prove right it takes
some work in linear algebra to prove
this but we will assume this
right so all matrices are all symmetric
right in particular The laplacian Matrix
is symmetric so it has an orthogonal
eigenvectors and eigenvalues
can we
are these eigenvalues interesting can we
do something of this
let's try to see some easy
easy properties of Laplace
here's the very first observation I
claim that all my eigenvalues of the
laplacian have to be non-negative
right in linear algebra terms it says
that my Matrix is going to be positive
semi-definite
why is this
here's an easy proof
if PSI is an eigenvector look at my
quadratic form PSI transpose L PSI
because it's an eigenvector I get Lambda
times I but that's just Lambda times
Norm of PSI squared
this is one so all the eigenvalues are
non-negative
and this is the step here
good so sorry here's the quadratic form
is non-negative by definition
because it involved a sum of squares
right so the quadratic form is
non-negative but the quadratic form is
exactly Lambda times the norm squared
and the norm is non-negative so Lambda
is non-negative thanks so I have the
inequality in the reverse Direction
right so quadratic form being
non-negative implies
all my eigen values are non-negative
in linear algebra terms this is denoted
as that my Matrix L is positive
semi-definite you see you'll see this
curly greater than equal to so L is
curly greater than equal to zero so L is
PST
is there any use for negative weights so
most of our applications will use
weights as non-negative
uh Negative Edge weights on a graph
LaPlace here and turn out to be
basically a general Matrix
a very difficult to deal with and
and that I haven't seen applications
where they pop up naturally and we don't
know what to do with it right so in our
in all our algorithmic applications the
laplacian will pop up with non-negative
good so another one more small piece of
notation from linear algebra we will
denote
uh this PSD notation so a curly greater
than equal to B to say that
a minus B right so a minus B has all
eigen values greater than equal to 0 or
a minus B is PST
uh it's called The Loner ordering uh it
defines a partial order on matrices not
all of matrices are comparable
all right so you can have
A and B where it's not true that a is
Curly greater than equal to or B is
curlic
but some of the matrices you can compare
and you and turns out to be a very
useful ordering for comparing weights
so here's an equivalent definition to
remember
so I will say that a currently create is
n equal to B if it holds for every
Vector X the quadratic form with respect
to a x transpose ax is greater than
equal to quadratic form with
respectively
right for most purposes this is actually
an easier definition to remember and
process right but it turns out this this
gives you a more uh an easier calculus
to sort of work with in more compact
notation
right but this is this is sort of the
way to remember what does it mean
what does the PHD ordering mean
everybody
okay with the definition of PC
excellent so so let's let's look at some
easy properties of the graph laplacian
I claim that the graph here's a very
simple one I claim that the graph
laplacian actually has a kernel
what does it mean to have a kernel it
means that a matrix l
that the graph will pass in L times the
all ones vector
is going to be 0.
any Vector when you multiply it with an
operator gives you zero that's called
that Subspace is called the kernel
so my graph laplacian has a kernel and
it contains the all ones vector
the proof is really simple now I will
use the alternative definition
the plus n times the all ones Vector is
D minus a times the all ones vector
but we all want multiplying with the all
ones Vector just takes row sums
the row sums of the degree Matrix give
you the weighted degree
you know some of the adjacency weighted
adjacency Matrix again give you the
degrees
30 degrees so the difference is zero
and I get the zero width
right so the all ones Matrix is in the
kernel of the LaPlace
in particular this means that my
smallest eigenvalue is zero
in fact all ones is an eigenvector with
eigenvalue zero
right because
laplacian times all ones gives you zero
times all ones
so I always have a laplacian always has
all ones as an eigen Vector with
eigenvalue 0.
yes question is the dimension of the
kernel is one
excellent question
that's exactly my next slide so the
question was is the dimension of Kernel
always one and that's the question we're
going to ask next
right it's exactly up there is this my
entire kernel can I have other vectors
in the kernel right can there be more
zero eigen values
this turns out to be a very interesting
question uh let's look at the following
like give me a vector in the corner
let's say it's X
right let me look at its quadratic form
so the quadratic form must be zero
because LX is 0. right but this means by
the definition of my quadratic form sum
over my edges okay sorry there was there
I should have put in a weight here but
let's consider an unweighted graph right
unit weighted graph for now so either
you have an edge with weight one or you
have no edges
some over my edges X U minus x v squared
is 0.
this is the sum of squares
so every term must be zero
right if every term is 0 I must have
that the vector satisfies that whenever
I have an edge
UV with positive weight right in the
general weighted case you should look at
edges with positively positive weight I
must have that the values are same
across the end points of the edge
right but from here now it's very easy
to infer that X must be constant on
every connected component if I focus on
edges with strictly positive weight
right ignore the edges with zero it
focus on Strictly positive weight edges
every connected component my Vector X
must be constant
but now I can infer some more from this
so what like this is a Subspace of
vectors
what is the dimension of the Subspace
it's the number of connected components
right
so in fact you exactly get the property
that the number of zero eigen values of
a laplacian
is exactly equal to the dimension of the
kernel
which is exactly the number of connected
components of the graph
right it sort of falls out of just
looking at the quadratic form
Ula plastic
right is this proof clear to all of us
so good so let's ask the flip side so so
we've already addressed the smallest ion
knowledge right we know that all
eigenvalues are non-negative
and we have zero eigenvalues equal to
the number of connected components
what about the largest eigenvalues
I claim we can bound them right like in
an interesting way so I will start again
with the quadratic form let's say x is
any vector I write the quadratic form
this should have a weight there let me
see if I can fix it quickly
foreign
[Music]
okay good
sorry about that so let's look at the
quadratic form for a weighted graph
I get the quadratic form which is some
over edges weight of the edge X U minus
x v Square
so this expression X2 minus XV squared
let me apply the simple inequality
which is that this is smaller than 2 x u
squared plus 2xv squared
so I get a common factor two way to sum
over edges weight of the edge X U
squared plus XV squared
for this I can now simplify I can
collect these by vertices
and for X U squared I will get the sum
of weights of the edges
that are incident on the vertex
U and that gives me
two times the quadratic form of X with
the weighted degree Matrix
that by itself is not a bound on the
upper eigenvalue but if I wanted to do
that I can just look at the largest
entry in the diagonal and say that this
is smaller than
two times the maximum weighted degree in
the graph
times the norm of x squared
so this means that my largest eigenvalue
is bounded by 2 times the maximum
weighted degree
it's it's a somewhat useful bound but it
turns out this proof showed us something
stronger rather than looking at the
bound on the largest tagging value it in
fact proved that my laplacian
is smaller in the PST ordering than two
times the diagonal degree Matrix
right this was just just before we chose
the maximum weighted degree saying the
quadratic form with respect to for X
with the quadratic form of the laplacian
is smaller than two times the quadratic
form with respect to the weighted degree
Matrix for all matrices
that's exactly the statement that the
laplacian is smaller than
two times the diagonal degree Matrix in
the PHD ordering
this turns out to be a very interesting
the far more interesting statement than
the largest eigenvalue actually
in fact
out of this will pop what is called the
normalized laplacian
so
if I consider the Matrix so here's my
definition of a normalized laplacian
which is D minus half diagonal degree
minus half
the laplacian diagonal degree minus off
so I am taking the LaPlace in
multiplying with diagonal matrix on the
on the both on both sides the same
diagonal matrix to make the diagonal all
once
right the diagonal entry of this
normalized laplacian is now all once
or proof actually in fact exactly sure
that this Matrix has an eigenvalue
that's always upper bounded by two
foreign
right so this is a simple manipulation
because like multiplying like the
quadratic form sort of the space of
quadratic form remains
basically unchanged
and here are let me just conclude I will
let me also give you like few very
simple exercises to work with the
normalized laplacian
the number of eigenvalues of this okay
even before this let me say this it's
easy to show that n is also positive
semi-definite all as eigen values are
non-negative
right in fact for this Matrix the number
of eigen values that are exactly equal
to 2
is exactly equal to the number of
bipartite components of the graph
and it's a very similar proof to the
connected components this time you will
get every connected component where your
sine flips on every Edge
right so your dimension will be exactly
equal to the number of bipartite
components
the simple properties from laplacian
still carry over so the number of
eigenvalues with zero is still equal to
the number of total number of components
and you can also explicitly write the
first eigenvector as the diagonal degree
Matrix and
okay that's the end of our first star a
great place to leave with a few
exercises
and we will continue with this tomorrow
thank you
thank you very much you can maybe do one
quick question before the lunch break
any questions
that is right before we watch right all
right so then um just quick schedule so
we have a lunch break now uh the next
talk will be here at 1 30 in the
afternoon this is the end of graph
linear algebra today in the afternoon
we'll be having a graph data structures
with attachable starting at 1 30 PM if I
recall correctly um in this sequence
with sushant we'll resume tomorrow
morning at 9 30. so have a great lunch
break see you all shortly and let's
thank sushant again
[Applause]
absolutely